[Musique]
laurent saint-honoré bonjour bonjour
monsieur livory bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique la première alors vous êtes
tête de liste de choisissons d'avancer
ensemble
vous êtes qualifiés pour le second tour
des municipales à saint joseph le 15
mars ce dernier lors du premier tour
vous avez obtenu 11,38 % des suffrages
exprimés soit environ 490 voix
quelle analyse faites vous de ce premier
tour de ce scrutin
ben une analyse très positive pour mon
équipe parce que effectivement c'était
la première fois qu'une présomption
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un contexte
particulier à saint-joseph parce qu'elle
n'est pas moins de neuf candidats est
arrivé au deuxième tour avec
pratiquement 12 % des votants
ça a été une réussite et il faut dire
aussi que par rapport au report des
élections
on a pu avoir un retour de la population
donc on leur remet ainsi d'être au
deuxième tour
et eux aussi beaucoup ont été
agréablement surpris de voir que cette
équipe puisse être au deuxième tour
lakovic 19 n'a pas eu d'impact selon
vous sur ce premier tour si quand même
parce que quand on voit le pourcentage
de votants et on a rencontré beaucoup de
personnes après qui nous ont fait part
de leur inquiétude en a beaucoup qui
n'ont pas été votées par rapport à ça là
pourquoi pour ce second tour n'y a pas
d'entente entre vous camille marlette
simon nous ré ou encore manu larrouy
clarmont désir pour faire une seule
langue c'est à dire que il ya une
proposition c'est vrai
j'ai rencontré camille mallette mais la
proposition n'était pas clair et ils
s'étaient déjà rangés avec tous les
autres
effectivement choisissons d'avancer
ensemble nous avons une équipe citoyenne
de socioprofessionnels de très bon
niveau des gens de qualité dans
différents corps de métiers que sont le
btp l'urbanisme la santé l'éducation
avec une moyenne d'âge de 47 ans et
c'était compliqué pour moi c'était très
difficile de laisser ce groupe d'aller
dans des circonstances je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'irai pour négocier un poste
c'est pas vraiment dans mes valeurs et
le travail que nous avons effectué était
tellement intéressant que à l'unanimité
nous avons fait pour aller jusqu'au bout
d'accord un poste mais quand même vous
n'êtes pas très loin de monsieur de
monsieur marleix tu as quelques voix ça
aurait pu être plus qu'un poste va être
bi un binôme ça pourrait être un binôme
oui ben justement mais vous le dit
justement là les cas on n'était pas
significatif donc à partir de là je vois
pas pourquoi j'allais laisser 90% de
l'équipe des gens très compétents des
gens dynamiques pour pouvoir aller
quasiment seul sur une liste d'accords
alors si vous êtes élu le 28
quel sera votre votre projet votre grand
projet alors nous avons deux axes en
parlant de projet il ya ce qui s'appelle
les grands projets structurants qui ont
un certain coût et qui demande un
certain temps à mettre en place c'est à
dire le temps de l'étude le temps des
appels d'offres et quel que soit le
projet que vous allez faire que ce soit
la structure que vous vouliez mettre en
place la la première pierre ne vivra pas
le premier joue pas avant quatre à cinq
ans c'est à dire ce sont des projets je
dirais sur deux mandatures
ça c'est une chose donc et en plus ce
type de projet nous souhaitons faire la
population participé à l'étude de ces
projets que ce soit la construction
d'une mairie
quel que soit un projet sportif quel que
soit le projet sinon nous nous avons axé
notre politique sur l'humain nous avons
axé notre politique sur la proximité
nous avons étudié analysé ce qui fait la
vie des gens tous les jours c'est à dire
la petite enfance par exemple à saint
joseph nous n'avons pas de crèche
nous ne choisissons pas dada il n'y a
pas de crèches municipales nous ne
choisissons pas de construire une crèche
par contre il ya peu près cette
structure à sept ou huit structures à
saint joseph
il s'agit de les aider de les aider par
des conventions
il y a un problème à ce niveau parce que
certains parents paie très cher
la crèche pas moi donc il faut faire un
service de façon à permettre la
coordination entre la caf
la septième et la mairie pourquoi ce
sera plus accessible à certains parents
il y à là jeunesse je lis bien
développée dans mon premier tiers de
chez vous il ya un problème sur la
jeunesse à saint joseph
les jeunes en difficulté il faut les
intégrer dans le projet de dynamisation
du bourg par exemple et puis il ya aussi
les personnes âgées une somme population
vieillissante
je le vois tous les jours j'ai fait
beaucoup de porte à porte et ces
personnes âgées ont besoin de services
ils ont besoin d' aide alors dernière
question 20 secondes
comment vous vivez ce second tour avec
cette crise sanitaire comment ça
s'organise pour vous vous faites vous
toujours du porte à porte vous faites du
terrain va plus vous utilisez les les
limites j'allais y réseaux sociaux alors
vous savez cette pandémie nous a permis
de réfléchir énormément et depuis le 11
dates où nous a permis de déconfinement
nous avons fait beaucoup de porte à
porte bien sûr en respectant les gestes
de barrières et mon équipe et moi nous
avons eu la chance d'avoir un réseau
d'avoir travaillé et nous avons pu
bénéficier de masques alors sur notre
compte de campagne on a on en a plus
financé à peu près 4000 on en a eu à peu
près 4000 ans dont on a fait une
opération sur saint joseph qui a eu un
grand succès ça nous a permis de
rencontrer la population de leur dire
merci et et de les retrouver à 28
laurent saint-honoré je vous remercie